ich gehe mit max immer trainieren für
ein neues youtube projekt und auch so
allgemein damit ziemlich komplett
verstopft und ich komme eben zu spät
immer wirklich also ausnahmslos wir
gehen meistens 39 oder so und es war wie
immer 9 uhr 28 ich springe aufs motorrad
max schreibt ich bin schon da ich fahre
innere kanalstraße in köln also eine
schnellstraße die einmal komplett um
köln herum führt es fängt an zu regnen
es wird nass ich bin mega abgefragt
welche zu spät wind & fire es anfängt zu
regnen merkel scheiße baustelle ich
brauche zeit 15 minuten innere
kanalstraße besteht aus drei spuren die
in beide richtungen führen und auf
meiner seite war nur eine frau wegen der
baustelle also falsch auf den
grünstreifen zwischen den beiden spuren
also rechts von mir fahren die leute in
meine fahrtrichtung links von mir
baggern die autos so mit 70 oder so lang
dreht den hahn komplett auf war über
diesen grünstreifen mit 70 oder so an
den fast stehenden autos vorbei weil ich
habe nun mal ein motorrad was offroad
fahren kann habe ich gedacht dann kann
ich da auch herr ball endlich knaller
komplett durch die ampel vor mir wird
grün
ich ziehe ein merke dass aber ein paar
autos noch nicht losgefahren sind voll
in die eisen mein motorrad ohne abs
natürlich eine komplette reifen
blockieren und ich würde sagen ich war
da wahrscheinlich noch so auf 35 km h
oder so oder 30 mein motorrad rutscht
weg
ich schmeiße das so recht nach rechts
weg das leidet genau zwischen zwei autos
durch erwischt aber noch das eine auto
hinten an der heckstoßstange und ich
knalle ich hab das gar nicht so richtig
mitbekommen ich knalle mit also
natürlich t shirt und kurzer hose runter
die also gegen die heckstoßstange von so
einem opel corsa und drehe mich so
komplett unter das auto also ich bin weg
dagegen geknallt und und das auto
gerutscht hoch und sehen nur so auspuff
über mir also ich mag wirklich unter dem
auto mein motorrad link rechts neben
zwei autos also erstmal weiß man im
moment ja nie direkt ob irgendwas
passiert ist also ob man sich gerade
verletzt hat oder nicht
ich war so komplett unter schock
stehe so auf zack so mir fällt erstmal
nichts auf an mir probiert mein motorrad
auszumachen dann guckt mich eine frau so
an sagt sie müssen sofort ins
krankenhaus und ich denke so scheiße
alter jetzt sehe ich nicht was bei mir
los ist oder dass das irgendwas an mir
kaputt ist hat sich alles normal
angefühlt ich gehe erst mal auf den
seitenstreifen chip mein motorrad weg
von der anderen straßenseite kommt ein
notarzt der durch zufall da
vorbeigefahren ist kommt und sagt ey
alles gut so probier mal mach mal das
macht man das macht man das ich mache so
alles oh mein vater ist auch nach papa
ist tut mir leid ich hab dich leider ein
wenig angelogen als wir weil ich
unterwegs waren und du gefragt hast ob
meine hüftschmerzen von einem
motorradunfall kam ja tatsächlich kamen
die von einem motorradunfall auf jeden
fall bin ich dagegen geballert g auf den
grünstreifen märkte so ok ist
anscheinend nichts also alles bestens
dann wusste ich aber okay jetzt gibt es
komplette abfahrt mitversicherung der
typ will seine chance heckstoßstange
repariert haben um mode robert ist
kaputt so dann kommt der typ von dem
corsa angelaufen und ich denke so okay
jetzt kommen polizeimotorrad ist
natürlich komplett legal es hat nicht zu
viel leistung der db killer ist
natürlich drin die spiegel die ich habe
sind natürlich legal angebracht die
blinker sind natürlich legal
also alles in allem wäre es wirklich
unangenehm gewesen wenn jetzt die
polizei gekommen wäre und ich irgendwas
versicherungs mäßig hätte machen müssen
der typ kommt zu mir und sagte also
hätte nicht so gesagt er war so 40 kommt
und sagt ey weißt du was vergisst die
heckstoßstange so schönen tag noch ich
war einfach weiter hat er obwohl die
heckstoßstange war auf der einen seite
wirklich rausgerissen also richtig
kaputt und da waren kratzer drin hat er
gesagt scheiß drauf so weitergeht kein
problem
januar druck absoluter ihren mann die
einzige möglichkeit warum er weiter
gefahren ist weil er selber dreck am
stecken hatte oder so also weil er
betrunken versuchen die story geht aber
noch weiter freunde also jetzt gleich
jetzt erst richtig wild fahrt zum
training trainiere merke okay an mir ist
eigentlich nichts also mir gehts
komplett gut außer meine hüfte to daddy
tut auch bis heute noch weh
das ist jetzt so zwei wochen oder so
alles easy so ich erfreue mich zwei tage
lang daran dass alles gut ist dass mein
motorrad gut geht es mir gut geht dass
sich niemand anderen verletzt habe und
dass das dass der keinen stress gemacht
hat wegen versicherung dann treffe ich
mich abends mit homies stellen mein
motorrad bei einem kumpel ab wir
verbringen den abend zusammen und beim
nachhause fahren alle gehen ihren weg
alle gehen nach hause musste ich noch
mal zurück zu meinem kumpel und das
motorrad abholen ich wohl mein motorrad
fahre fahrrad fahre fahrer auf die
aachener straße erkennt auf eine ampel
zu dies roth hinter mir autos natürlich
sobald es ist so ich stehe als erster an
ampel die ampel wird grün
ich will nach links abbiegen brähmig
nach links um ok da kommt eine bahn
lasst die bahn durch bremse runter auf 0
km/h auf einmal gibt es im übelsten
schlagzeug nach hinten ist mir so eine
frau also ist mir so ein pärchen einfach
komplett von hinten ins motorrad
reingefahren einfach angefahren nicht
geguckt so komplett rein geballert da
waren zwei tage oder so zwischen neue
teile fürs moderieren man denkt so alles
kann nicht sein innerhalb von zwei tagen
knallt mir jetzt noch eine person hinten
drauf ich stelle mein motorrad ab und
sagt ey bewegt das auto keinen meter ich
muss das erst abfotografieren
dann kommt die person draußen sagt
direkt so wird die keine polizei bitte
keine polizei bitte keine polizei und
ich denke auch der jetzt gibt es auch
noch hier so einen kopf weg dann sage
ich direkt so hast du besoffen sagt sich
so ja da war es einfach ein pärchen das
auf der aachener straße abends unterwegs
war und komplett gesoffen hatte ich habe
das sogar gebrochen als sie mit mir
gesprochen aber er hat keine
unangenehmen leute sondern so 23 würde
ich sagen irgendwelche studenten in
irgendeinem kleinen wagen einfach
gesoffen auto gefahren um mir dann
hinten rein geballert ich denke es wird
jetzt kann man jetzt nicht wahr sein
dann übels die ganze zeit an so überlegt
erst mal alles fotografiert so zeugen
kurz aufgehalten elcom markus hergibt
mal nummer und so dann die ganze zeit
überlegt etwas mache ich entweder hole
ich mir jetzt einfach bargeld von denen
sagt ey du hast gesoffen so wenn ich
nicht die polizei holen soll dann gib
mir so und so viel auf die hand da habe
ich gedacht als du willst auch hier
niemandem erpressen
zweite option ich rufe die polizei die
personen verliert ihren führerschein und
ich bekomme geld über die versicherung
was kaputt ist dritte option ich mache
den absoluten ehren mut und vertrauen
smith vertrau der person holen nicht die
polizei und claire einfach so mit
versicherung bitte euch einmal kurz
abzustimmen zwischen bargeld wegen so
polizei und versicherung politik oder
versicherungen und ehrenmann die
absolute mehrheit von 53 prozent hat
geschrieben oder hat abgestimmt für
versicherungen und ihrem mann das
bedeutet keine polizei rufen nicht
erpressen daten aufnehmen und sich das
geld über die versicherung wiederholen
31 prozent haben gesagt polizei und
versicherung ich habe im endeffekt mich
wie die absolute mehrheit entschieden
und gesagt so ich finde es hat er gesagt
ich finde es übel scheiße was du machst
so dass du meine gesundheit gefährt ist
und so und die von allen anderen ich
will dir aber den führerschein nicht
wegnehmen lassen habe die zeugen dazu
geholt haben das alles gehört alles
gesehen ich habe alle daten von denen
aufgenommen und jetzt hole ich mir geld
von der versicherung für die sachen nica
prozent und kann euch die situation
genau zeigen im prinzip hier ständig das
war mein motorrad ich bin hier parameter
losgefahren dann angehalten und die es
mir halt komplettieren und darauf gewann
hat ihre schürze war auch komplett ab
dass hier sind meine beiden ehren
ahlmann zeugen hier ist der beifahrer
und die besoffene ist keine ahnung
als wäre das nicht genug gewesen sind
wir zwei tage später drehen gegangen auf
ganz schnelle welle für einen kumpel der
muk gemacht dann werdet ihr
wahrscheinlich auch kennen genau waren
wir für schnell was drehen damit er was
hat um wenn sein neuer song kommt damit
der video hochladen kann
abgesehen davon das ist ein absoluter
abba songs waren wir eben dann drehen
für dieses für diesen kleinen trailer
ich sollte mit dem motorrad so ein
bisschen rum driften und einfach da sein
und ein bisschen rum fahren meine hüfte
hat noch vom ersten unfall geschmerzt
mein motorrad ist noch kaputt vom
zweiten also habe ich mir gedacht
wahrscheinlich wäre es das schlimmste
wenn ich einfach beim dreh komplett an
die grenzen von denen gehe was ich kann
bis wir die perfekten aufnahmen haben
und hat mich einfach ein drittes mal
gelegt wo ich habe in einer woche
mein motorrad was ich gerade frisch habe
was ich jetzt seit anderthalb monaten
fahre unfall selber gebaut jemand
reingefahren und einfach für eine
aufnahme die die karre nochmal
weggeschmissen beim driften junge wie
viel pech kann man haben ja mehlig das
habe ich mich als erstes auch gefragt
dann ist mir aufgefallen
der erste unfall ich nichts gemacht habe
da war ich verursacher ich bin über
einen grünstreifen gefahren dann auf der
straße im nassen weggerutscht komplett
meine schuld liegt 0 fremd einwirkung
gar nicht zweite ok hatte ich überhaupt
keinen einfluss drauf aber dritte auch
absolut unnötig mich da so dumm
wegzuschmeißen das war die geschichte
wie ich in einer woche drei unfälle
gehabt haben ich hoffe es 2